tengo una ecuación muy simple escrita
por aquí a más b igual hace y lo que
quiero que pensemos es que si sabemos
que es un número entero así que digamos
que por aquí pongo los números enteros
déjenme hacer por aquí a mi conjunto de
los números enteros y voy a escribirlo
aquí
pero sí voy a suponer que es un número
entero así que vive por aquí voy a poner
por aquí
e imagina que también ve es un entero
por lo tanto ve puede ser el mismo
entero que puede ser uno distinto pero
para que se distinga a dv
voy a poner por aquí a ve por aquí tengo
a b y b también es un número entero y mi
pregunta va a ser ok cuando sumamos
estos dos números enteros estaremos
seguros de que vamos a obtener otro
número entero es decir podemos asegurar
que ese también va a ser un número
entero y te encargo que pausa el vídeo y
pienses un poco en esto y al hacerlo
puedes usar algunos ejemplos de esta
suma para poder averiguarlo no sé podrás
pensar qué va
no sé supongamos que también vale uno y
entonces en este caso se valdría dos que
también es un número entero pero mi
pregunta es siempre pasar a esto así que
es momento de que pausa es el vídeo
bueno pues la respuesta es que si hay
varias formas de probarlo pero no voy a
entrar mucho en esos detalles por ahora
lo que sí quiero decirte es que cuando
tú tienes una situación así es decir
cuando tú tomas dos elementos de un
conjunto en este caso dos elementos de
los números enteros y le aplicas una
operación en este caso de operaciones la
suma siempre que obtengas un resultado
que nos dé un elemento del mismo
conjunto ojo recuerda que también el
resultado podría ser a o podría ser b o
algún otro elemento distinto del
conjunto así que vamos a ponerlo por
aquí voy a poner por aquí hacer voy a
poner por aquí hacer para que no se
encima con ninguno de los otros dos así
que pensemos en un elemento distinto y
bueno siempre que tengas este caso en
donde tenemos una operación que en este
caso es la suma y se la aplicamos a dos
elementos del conjunto
el resultado está en el conjunto es
decir te quedas en el conjunto en este
caso se vive en el conjunto porque es un
elemento de él una forma de pensarlo es
que éste va a ir a dar justo por acá
este también porque estamos aplicando la
operación suma cuando ves una situación
de esta forma decimos que este conjunto
en este caso el conjunto de los números
enteros es cerrado bajo la suma y es más
déjeme escribirlo en este caso el
conjunto con
de los números enteros de los enteros en
ceros es cerrado bajo la suma es cerrado
cerrado bajo la suma bajo
zuma
y esta palabra ha cerrado o cerradura es
el concepto general es más déjame
escribirlo por aquí se va
a dura y este concepto cerradura puede
ser que lo hayas escuchado en tus cursos
de bachillerato o tal vez en algún curso
de matemáticas de un nivel superior
puede ser que pienses que es un concepto
bastante avanzado pero lo único que está
diciendo es lo siguiente tú tienes una
operación la cual puedes aplicar a
elementos de un conjunto y además cada
vez que aplicas la operación a todos los
elementos del conjunto obtienes otro
elemento de ese mismo conjunto es decir
te quedas en el conjunto entonces es
cuando decimos que el conjunto es
cerrado bajo la operación en este caso
bueno la operación fue la suma y por eso
hablamos de cerrado bajo la suma y bueno
también te puedes preguntar acerca de
otro tipo de operaciones por ejemplo se
irán a dejar ponerlo así es el conjunto
de los números enteros
de los enteros será cerrado se errado
bajo y vamos a pensar si el conjunto de
los números enteros es cerrado bajo
primero la multiplicación
sí
la canción después pensemos en la
división
vamos a pensar también en la división de
acción y pensemos también en la resta
voy a bajar un poco esta pantalla y
pensemos también en la resta en la
revista
era el conjunto de los números enteros
cerrados bajo la multiplicación bajo la
división o bajo la resta y es momento de
que pau self vídeo y también pienses en
esto así que manos a la obra pensemos
primero en la operación multiplicación
si tú tomas dos enteros y los
multiplicas bueno de hecho siempre vas a
obtener otro número entero entonces el
conjunto de los números enteros ese rato
bajo la multiplicación en este caso es
cierto y ahora qué pasa con la división
bueno es bastante sencillo probar el
caso en el cual tomamos la división de
dos números enteros y no obtenemos un
número entero por ejemplo hagamos uno
simple
imagínate que vale 11 entre 2 bueno en
este caso tanto el uno como el dos
números enteros y si los dividimos que
me va a dar bueno me va a dar un medio y
este no es un número entero así que si
este es el conjunto de mis números
enteros por acá puedo tener al conjunto
de los números racionales dejar poner
por acá tengo a los racionales recuerda
que todo número entero es racional pero
no todo número racional es entero este
de aquí entonces date cuenta que un
medio su número racional estaríamos en
este caso tenemos por aquí al 1 tenemos
por aquí al 2 y cuando aplicamos la
operación división entonces nos salimos
de este conjunto y llegamos al un medio
que es un número irracional algún medio
que estaría por aquí así que nos salimos
del conjunto de los números enteros
tenemos algo que no es entero pero es un
número racional entonces el conjunto de
los números enteros no es cerrado bajo
la división y la resta claro y de nuevo
no voy a hacer una prueba rigurosa pero
al tomar cualesquiera dos enteros al
restar los vas a obtener de nuevo un
número entero el objetivo en general es
darte una breve introducción a la noción
de cerradura cerradura es un concepto
clave es decir la idea de que si tú
tienes un conjunto
y si le aplicas una operación a ese
conjunto y siempre obtienes un elemento
de ese conjunto entonces ese conjunto es
cerrado bajo esa operación no importa
cuál es el conjunto que tomes en este
caso estamos tomando los números enteros
y hablamos de bueno la suma la
multiplicación la división y la resta
pero no sé podrás pensar en cualquier
otro conjunto
por ejemplo el conjunto de los
polinomios y ver si es cerrado bajo la
suma que en efecto lo es o pensar en el
conjunto de los racionales y pensar si
son cerrados bajo la operación
exponencia ción en fin puedes pensar
muchos casos pero espero que esto te dé
una buena idea de lo que significa el
concepto de cerradura y de lo que
significa el concepto de que un conjunto
sea cerrado bajo alguna operación